tras intercambios telefónicos con sus
homólogos ruso y ucraniano el viaje en
persona emanuel macrón viajará primero a
moscú el lunes y luego a kiev el martes
con la ambición de avanzar hacia una
desescalada en la cuestión ucraniana
reuniones bilaterales mientras que
washington ha subido el tono este fin de
semana indicando el temor a una invasión
a gran escala de ucrania las tropas de
élite estadounidenses aterrizaron en
polonia el domingo por la mañana no muy
lejos de la frontera con ucrania una
señal de que washington se toma en serio
la amenaza de una inversión rusa estamos
en una ventana de oportunidad en la que
podría ocurrir algo y es que una
escalada militar y una invasión de
ucrania podrían ocurrir en cualquier
momento
el presidente de valdés se compromete
con los aliados refuerza y tranquiliza a
los socios del flanco oriental
pero kiev está relativizando el riesgo
por ahora el jefe de la diplomacia
ucraniana pide cautela ante los
pronósticos apocalípticos y una solución
diplomática con moscú antes de su
reunión con vladimir putin el presidente
francés indicó en las columnas del
journal du dimanche que el objetivo
geopolítico
russian no era ucrania sino aclarar las
reglas de convivencia con la otan y la
unión europea rusia niega cualquier
intención de invadir a su vecino sin
embargo ha concentrado casi 100.000
soldados en sus fronteras con ucrania
movimientos militares inaceptables para
occidente desde hace varios meses moscú
exige que se garantice que ucrania nunca
entrará en la otan una demanda rechazada
en bloque por los aliados